circuit personne ne pensait qu'on
gagnerait quoi que ce soit quand on a
adopté shield ça va le faire
on va paris je la demande en mariage
elle oui mais je suis content si toi tu
es heureux et surtout pas de bêtises
j'arrive pas à croire qu'il fasse sa
demande la même semaine que les
internationale est ce que c'est vrai que
chez lignac ne me dites pas vous
abandonner les internationale et si on
allait aux internationale on ferait
justin qui touchent aucune matière ou là
des milliers qu'ils nomment d'accord
allez vous promener mais on parle plus
de courses de tekel s'est pas compris a
été la seule qui pourrait me faire des
yeux de chien battu ici c'est chez lui
parce que c'est un chien et refuse que
me fasse et culpabiliser tous les deux
c'est clair s'il seul endroit où je me
sens vraiment vivant
disons qu'il se pourrait que j'ai
quelques investissements à surveiller
marie-rose merriweather industrie est le
principal sponsor du championnat c'est
très très mal si vous n'êtes pas assez
sur le banc au moment votre course est
annoncé alors miss paris rose cours à
votre place donc vous pouvez signer ce
formulaire
donc j ai bien réfléchi les
international pourrait nous faire du
bien parti pour les autres nationale
la france et le japon singapour avec 64
pays rassemblés ici aujourd'hui et ils
veulent tous le titre de champion de
champion du monde
aux saluts temps johnny salue ce qui
comprend la voiture fume ça lui arrive
bon je vais monter voir comment va demi
teinte fini il est si tranquille vous
êtes les familles tient patrick use les
derniers débit hsi percée l'air une
internationale des winners sur le
slovaque
la russie a été évincé la chérie qu'on a
récupéré et il fonce enfin vous ne
pensez tout de même pas que j'ai fait
fortune en m'entraînant d'éthique
marie-rose industrie à cloner ton chien
aime chez les va courir contre toute une
bande d'autres services
l'histoire et toi puisque tu es mené 4 1
me
incroyable vous